welcome to the heavy spoiler show I'm
your host Paul and the secret Invasion
finale is now sitting at eight percent
on Rotten Tomatoes but we're gonna
forget about that because the future is
bright with the Loki season 2 trailer
dropping online right now just forget
about it now when we last left the
adopted brother of the God of Thunder he
just reached tea he remains with his
multiversal variant Sylvie arriving at
his castle seeking knowledge he could be
seen eating an apple and acting as a
form of Temptation for the pair the Adam
and eve-esque metaphors didn't stop
there with Sylvie casting out Loki after
killing this quote-unquote god Loki was
left with a version of the TVA where he
who remains varying kangarooled over the
agency and we of course know from Conor
Mania that there are others messing with
the time stream that should be fully
caught up and if you liked the video
then please hit the thumbs up button and
don't forget to subscribe for break down
inside this every day by the way huge
thank you for clicking this now let's
get into Loki season 2.
please
obey
hello
we have a little bit of a situation we
wanted to run by you Mobius wow great to
see you again
that that's what's been happening wow
time slipping were you times you know
that yeah you've seen that yeah can you
fix that no
it's impossible to time slipping the TVA
I know but we just saw it happen
yeah now the trailer opens on kihu
Kwan's character who is an inventor this
could be riffing off his character in
The Goonies who was also an event to do
and they might be kind of just basing it
around that to give it a little nut to
his past and we actually know a fair bit
about him from the plot leaks and rumors
and for the first part of the video I
want to break down what's apparently
revealed about him in the first episode
and though this might not be true skip
ahead if you don't want to know that'll
be about a minute and uh then we'll
continue without the spoiler heavy stuff
there so yeah go go go go go go go go go
so can we get some toast posted on
Instagram recently that qwan's character
will go under the name aerobaros in case
you don't know this is a name that comes
from mythology and it's said to be a
snake that eats its own tail it
represents self-destruction and the
causal Loop that the TVA are currently
on as he who remains told us the Cycles
happen many times before and the path
they've chosen normally devolves into
multiversal war with he who remains
coming out on top and then destroying
the Multiverse where Mobius goes any
calls him OB so I'm guessing that the
these rumors are indeed true as for Aura
Boris himself he's supposed to be the
person who creates all of the tba's
technology which is why we see him in a
room that holds many of their items the
First episodes actually meant to have
Loki slipping backwards and forwards in
time and he ends up creating a device
that can help keep him steady in the
trailer we see several versions of the
TVA with one being a darker one that
could show this is either the future or
the past we're also meant to learn that
he who remains dying as though below to
the time stream and thus he has to
create something known as the time Loom
to bring it all back together again
might not be true but yeah I thought it
was worth talking about because Cowan
get some toast is normally pretty
accurate I think it's important to bring
up that auroboros was also a character
in The null time zone who was actually a
judge in she-hulk's trial anyway from
here we see Loki across different points
warping back and forth one of them looks
like this same location that there were
shots of Sylvia when she was working at
McDonald's we actually see this point
later on in the teaser and this has her
wearing a name badge with five stars on
it so well done in there you've done
loads of good customer service there by
the looks of it and I have to say that
when I had when I seen this shot I'm
loving it now now perhaps she's decided
to actually go and just have a normal
life instead of being she who remains
there was a leaked shot of her on the
couch I had her listening to 70s record
so I'm guessing that this is building
off the back of that she was of course
hunted for her whole life by the TVA so
maybe now she just wants to relax listen
to Abba and become a dancing queen in
the 70s you could say she's Bjorn again
either way we get another shot of Loki
in front of a piranha Power Sport which
I actually couldn't find that much on
the first season had a way of doing
stuff where the funk products would show
up in varying timelines so yeah if
that's a real place then let me know
below but I at least couldn't find it
and I think it's sort of doing that an
important detail here is that there are
jet skis and that might even be Mobius
in the back looking at one it's
difficult to make out but he of course
dreamed of going on one and this could
be from his life before he was snatch by
the TVA I have been pulled through time
between the past and the present hello
if what I saw is true
understand between this world and other
destruction only one way to find out
a little good old-fashioned legwork
listen we have different styles you're a
man of action which is fine
I take a more slow deliberate cerebral
approach
it's really good buy
now from here we cataloki running into
another vision of himself reading from a
TBA manual this is symbolic for a number
of reasons because it shows that the
organization obviously hasn't been
destroyed it's also what I'm guessing is
a rule book cementing that the rules are
still in place I think this might either
be a future offshoot of him or someone
from the past either I am constantly
warping back and forth shows he's not
really stuck in a certain place and that
he's constantly being torn across time
now this is obviously riffing on the
first season though when Honda B15 did
it when he was trying to escape he's
clearly stuck here though and being
controlled by someone else who we aren't
fully aware of either way man's busting
on moves that make him a better dancer
than Michael Jackson and he won't stop
until he gets enough which was a bad pun
hey now I feel like a lot of the early
part of this season will center around
him trying to convince the others at the
TVA about what's really going on at the
end of season 1 Mobius had no idea who
he was and he was even convinced that he
was from another department prepare take
it easy you're an analyst right what
division are you from what are you
talking about are you what's your name I
feel like we're immediately gonna go
from then to the interrogation slash
questioning thing with Loki trying to
calmly tell them what's going on how are
they gonna listen though unless he's
gonna have to show them through Force
exactly what's going on I sort of see it
like being like a game when you kind of
know all the internets of it and can
just speed run to the end and I'm
guessing that he's gonna race to the
timekeepers and behead the main one
which is why we get a shot in which its
head can be seen on the ground also
important to bear in mind that Jonathan
Majors voiced these in the series and
they sounded similar to his version of
immortus their beginning
watch
the Multiverse
of us
and we then get a shot of Sylvie tearing
up a vinyl record likely ripping off
that shot that we talked about before I
really get the feeling here that she's
tried to go off and have her own life
and she's destroying this record because
of how isolated the role can be we
actually get a shot of the destroyed
Castle later on in the teaser with what
looks like he who remains body still he
who remains in there as LV was just sat
in a room by herself listening to music
completely bored and this was much in
the same way that he who remains had his
own office but there's actually a lot of
theories going around at the moment that
katiki will appear in the series as an
older version of her and if you jump to
the Future on the current time stream
then that's going to bring you into
contact with her so it does make sense
from a timey wormy wibbly wobbly
perspective but it's just a dude
[Music]
also if you want to support us you can
check out our merch store just below the
video we've linked it up to the channel
now so you can buy some Theory time
merch right from there and I'll have a
theory that you're gonna look the best
you ever have and that's probably the
one Theory I've ever got right so make
sure you support the channel shout out
now we see Loki erasing a mural of the
three time Keepers through a TVA pruning
stick these are used to remove
alterations in the timeline having been
made from the essence of a life however
they can clearly be used to erase things
in general and send them all straight to
the void in the middle of it they're
holding up what would have been the
sacred timeline but we can see that
those are the branches on it now showing
how Judah he he remains being killed
that more are allowed destroying the
mural shows a true face behind the
timekeepers and we see as it reveals
Kang you can also catch that seven time
Keeper's head on the floor making me
think that Loki killed them is part of
the reveal now from this point on lokia
Mobius go into a lift where the ladder
hits the button that goes to the bottom
guessing this either goes to the
timekeepers directly or it might even
take them directly to obese anyway from
here we cut a Loki and Mobius arriving
at the Chicago's World Fair and what I'm
guessing is 1901 this is a real life
event in our history and we see them
Belling off the back of the quantum your
post-credits scene which showed one of
the Kang variants will be meeting in the
series that will be Victor timely with
us getting a scene from the season in
that film's post-credits scene in it
Loki and Mobius without a show being
presented by Victor timely an alias at
Kang went under in the comics arriving
back in 1901 he found in the town of
timely and built himself up as a central
figure there secretly working in
robotics he studied a make mechanical
slaves that would help him carry out his
nefarious plans for power judging by the
clips we've had they're gonna do things
slightly differently and Victor will
instead have a device that will allow
him to shape time time it shapes our
lives but perhaps
we can shape
it I wonder if this is actually the
prototype for the time Twisters that
allows the TBA to send their targets
back to certain points they could be
investigating it due to Loki being
affected by one and it does kind of make
sense that they'd go to him directly
also important to bear in mind that in
the comics Rebecca Terminator was
timely's girlfriend who joined him in
the town this was an alias ravona and
Slayer used and in her office in season
one we could catch the name on the
diploma on the wall might even explain
how she ended up at the TVA and
potentially Kang had a falling out with
her and then banished her to serve as a
member of the group before she became a
judge we know that she was the one who
lost Sylvie and we could learn more of
this backstory as we travel back in time
either way we do see ravana wearing
old-timey dresses and the teaser showing
that they likely linked up at some point
in the past at the end it seems like she
might be stuck in the void and
potentially coming face to face with a
life alokia Mobius sit down and enjoy
pie and we know from the leaked trailer
at d23 that this is gonna be a play on
the interrogation scene from the first
season the D20 E3 teaser had the pair in
a room together discussing how he wasn't
the bad guy and he listed off characters
who'd said he was like The Avengers Phil
Coulson and also Thanos interestingly we
never see Thanos calling him a bad guy
so maybe we'll get a reference what
happened between the pair before he sent
him to Earth in The Avengers
it's up to us
to save this place is this cracked okay
whatever we do
playing God
we are gods
but how do you choose
who lives
and who dies
make the hard choice
come on you're the god of mischief
always have been
always will be
a little over the top don't you think
spot on
now there's a couple of action shots of
them fighting a mysterious character and
we also see a premiere for the movie
called zaniac zaniac's actually a
character from the comics that's a
parasitic creature who we learn
originated from the dark dimension a
shout outs to our editor Matt who now is
the number 158 on the license plate of
the car there one five seven appears
when they arrive in 1901 so there could
be something going on with the numbers
either way we see an actor getting out
of a car and waving and this is who
lokia Mobius later on end up surrounding
I think he's the one who's stuck in the
doorway at the end too but the trailer
quality is pretty low so it's difficult
to tell aloki ends up using his Shadows
to grab her many duplicate himself as
well and this is a power that we've seen
him demonstrating in The Avengers now we
get a quick shot of Casey being led down
a dark and dank tunnel thingy in the
teaser we also get a shot of Hunter B15
wearing African dress along with a head
scarf and rings around her neck this is
the first time we've seen her out of her
uniform and I'm guessing that we'll see
her in the past and learn how she got
picked up by the TVA in season 1 we had
a brief moment where she seemed to
remember her life so we might end up
getting something along those lines
kinda leaning into MCE law here a bit
but due to them putting her in African
dress they may connect her with wakanda
and show how she was part of that world
or something or I might just be me
jumping into conclusions however at one
point we also see her as a doctor so
yeah might be barking up the wrong tree
on that either way I think this is gonna
basically give us the backstory of the
TVA and show that they were all variants
that were taken and then reformatted
into agents we saw them basically trying
to do that with the Loki variant in
season 1 and whilst his main Vision was
continuing in the 616 they were using
him to track down Sylvie now we also see
ravana sparking up a weapon and
throughout the teaser she seems to be
present in the 1901 stuff there seems to
be a proto-time stick and it looks like
the Comic version of the retroactive
cannon that wipes you out of existence
in case you don't know ravana is seen as
the love of Kang's life and in his
recent reboot at Arjun story he bumped
into several versions of her he was
always destined to watch her die or have
her turn on him unless he spent the
entirety of his life alone now we see
Mobius getting suited up into his space
suit and heading into what looks like a
timeline reactor I'm guessing this is
somewhere where the timeline's actually
a tangible thing and it looks like an
unstable thing that he then has to fix
could also Link in with Mobius having to
save Loki from falling and we have had
shots of the trailer where he's dropping
from a great height kind of feels like
it might be a little not at the falling
for 30 minutes I'm from Ragnarok but
obviously these are different versions
of Loki so that might be a reach now we
end with a giant Miss minutes who looks
like a toast clock and also see a mural
of lots of different kangs fighting
across the Multiverse this is clearly a
reference to the multiversal war and I'm
guessing that every TVA is going to be
like don't trust those other kangs now
we then get lots of different shots with
Loki going head to head with a DBA and
it's clear that he's threatening the
stability of the organization so
whoever's enjoy charge just want to take
him out this might actually be selfie
and the pair don't really seem to be
getting along though it seems like she's
kind of stepped down from the godhood
and just wants to be on her own she says
they shouldn't be Gods but Loki brings
up how they are and he is of course
known as the god of Mischief either way
there's lots of things going on and
potentially Kang could be going after
them or you know so we might still be in
charge now those are my thoughts on the
trailer I'm really excited for the show
and I'm hoping this rides the wrongs of
what's been going on with phase five I
didn't dislike secret Invasion but
towards the end it kind of fell off and
devolved into the title CGI fight trap
that's become the most played out part
of the genre She-Hulk even called it out
in her finale and then for them to do it
in the next one yeah come on mate you
better than that now what I admired
about Loki season 1 is that they got to
the finale and didn't do that on any
level and I think it worked better than
the other Disney Plus shows obviously
there's the whole thing happening with
Jonathan Majors as well that at the
moment the big elephant in the room I
don't want to comment on it too much as
it's one of those subjects where I feel
like everyone kind of brings down
baggage to it you've got people who
think it could be Hollywood covering up
for a violent man again whereas other
thing gets the media going off to
someone because of their race because
then those who think the woman's making
it up people who think he's pressuring
her into taking the fall and yeah I
think I'd rather just leave stuff up to
the judge and Jerry who will actually be
able to go through the evidence still
though I think it's worth acknowledging
that depending on what happens with him
it could affect how well the show's
received I think it's an enable that
he's a brilliant actor but if things
come out bad then it could end up
causing issues with the season the
Marvel filmed this before that so I
think they have the excuse there but if
they have to change things last minute
to recast then it may affect the ending
we don't know how it's gonna go but I
think having lucky versus Kang is a
central season theme is gonna make for a
very thrilling journey to me quantum
Mania kind of made him seem like a bit
of a chump in the end so I'm hoping this
secured him once more is a threatening
villain that we all know he can be and
the show itself looks fantastic too with
a being a clear evolution of what's come
before it seems like it's going to be a
brilliant follow-on from that and
hopefully it'll show Disney they need to
be making these things as actual Seasons
instead of six episode movie things
anyway I'd love to hear your thoughts on
the trailer so make sure you comment
below did I miss anything as well you
know we're kind of we're flying through
this but I think we got most of it but
yeah there will be some stuff that yeah
we definitely need to talk about now
please drop a like on the video and if
you want to support the channel as a
member of this spoiler Society then
please also click the join button you
get early access to videos every week
and it goes such a long way to helping
us out now if you want something else to
watch we've got a video on screen right
now talking about how long it is that
Roddy's actually been a scroll it's not
when you think uh we've got some good
evidence there so yeah definitely head
over there right after this by the way a
huge thing you've seen through the video
I've been Paul and I'll see you next
time take care peace